Kim Kardashian paying no mind to ex
Kanye West and his new love I'm just
rolling with it and it is what it is
last week reports surfaced that not only
are the embattled rapper and Bianca sent
Siri dating they might have tied the
knot but a source tells ET not so fast I
have an opinion the two did have a
ceremony and while the marriage is real
to Kanye and Bianca its legitimacy ends
there as for what the Kardashians star
thinks well the source reveals Kim isn't
paying attention to it and in the past
this same couldn't be said for Kanye
with Kim's love life God sent me from
that crash just so I could beat Pete
Davis fast forward to 2023 he's
forgotten about skeet and yay's new
focus is perhaps hinted in the title of
his latest track sensory overload the
lyrics invite plenty of speculation
quote and the Bible said I can't have
any more sex till marriage but it
remains to be seen if the sentiment led
to Kanye and Bianca's marriage mindset
just do something for my heart and seems
Bianca is a little bit of a mystery we
know she works at Yeezy the rapper's
fashion label and according to the
20-somethings LinkedIn profile she's
been on payroll since 2020 and her title
head of architecture though it's unclear
why the brand would need an architect
seeing as it's only done clothing up
until now
Meanwhile we're hearing Kim is focused
on the well-being of her children
co-parenting it's really hard you know
and that Echoes what Kim said last month
on Angie Martinez's IRL podcast and I
used to hold this guilt that I wasn't
there
to fix situations and I wasn't there
to put it all back together is it a
conscious thing to um not talk about it
I
definitely protected him and I still
will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids so in my
home my kids don't know anything that
goes on on the outside world this comes
as yay's still mid-controversy following
his string of anti-Semitic messages in
interviews and on social media the thing
about it being Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me now what and for
Kanye's Inner Circle it's reached a
Breaking Point
et's Source adds he's been acting
unstable lately and his friends are
hopeful that he can get help
[Music]